i tell you that this like [ __ ] ski
resort that we stayed at um
it was like its theme like what its
theme was like
it was very like inspired by i guess
like
american american like culture
right that sounds so bizarre a japanese
ski resort inspired by america it's
really weird it was it was like
kind of what i imagine yeah what kind of
what i imagine
a ferry would be like you know it had a
lot of
different um a lot of different
things for like 1950s carnival style i'd
say
oh weird in japan in japan whereabouts
did you guys go
hokkaido oh hokkaido yeah yeah but there
was some areas of this hotel that were
like
totally normal chill but there's a big
area that was like kids theme park yeah
carnival theme it was really weird so so
so they had like they had like these um
animatronics
um animated chucky cheese [ __ ] yeah like
yeah
exactly like that she's like some chucky
cheese [ __ ] right but i don't know when
they had bought these animatronics i
don't know when they had bought these
animatronics because we were just um me
and sydney were just
sitting there like and they'd play these
like songs right
they'd have these like animatronic
concerts like in in this like children's
area where you can buy [ __ ] burgers
and fries it was like an eating area
it's full on chuck e cheese yeah yeah
basically and these poor employees had
to listen these [ __ ] things sing all
day
yeah and so me and cindy were just
enjoying like a nice burger and
everything like that
and then this [ __ ] this [ __ ] like
[ __ ] animatronic dog or something
just starts just starts bigging up the
confederacy
yeah yeah yeah and i was just like i
had me in city had to double take to be
like did did we just
hear that correctly like what is what is
going on right now
because i walked past them and i was
like don't mind my own thing i'm like
why they're wearing confederate soldier
uniforms christ
so after we heard that we took like a
closer look at these animatronics right
to be like what is going on when did
they buy these and where did they buy
these from
and we saw one of the bears was uh
it was very let's say
not very tasteful 1920s like black
cartoon
uh character oh no yes yes
the lips were like massive you know and
and it had the stereotypical
cartoon black man accent of like 1920s
you know like the whole like uh i don't
even know what it is
literally if you go i know if you go and
watch like a disney
cartoon from the 1920s or a black person
with that like kind of like
stereotypical
accent they gave them and character yeah
and it was just that and it's like
it was like oh no oh no oh no oh no no
why why and uh yeah these
things you can't make that [ __ ] off
these people
these poor japanese tourists all these
these poor japanese toys are just like
ah american culture yeah kids are just
like running around being like
mama what's the confederacy i'm just
like
nothing weirder than that thing standing
next to a miku
like is that a miku thing
oh no oh no
oh that's oh that is that was a really
good result though it's really cheap
it was a really good resort really good
resort like that fantastic jesus christ
it is one of those things you're like
this is great what is going on here why
is this a thing
why is this here yeah it's like you know
you have that like your 90 year old aunt
who has that one piece of memorabilia
away like auntie you should
probably throw that away probably not
talk about that yeah probably
get rid of that yeah yeah i mean to give
to give them the benefit of the doubt i
don't
think that anyone there knew yeah they
don't know
yeah but it's the matter of like you
know when tourism comes back in right
like
oh it's been there for decades well
clearly yeah yeah
you know how has no like tourists come
up and being like
you know what that is right like it's
probably not a good idea
yeah i wanted to think of like you know
because obviously in the past like
you know five six years it's been a very
hot hot topic yeah yeah yeah yeah
and it's only now where we've really
started to be like we should probably
get rid of all that [ __ ] yeah
it's not a good idea so i wonder yeah i
i i wonder though i wonder is anybody
anyone sent them an email
letting them know hey uh love the
animatronics
they're great they're really great dog
is cute but
maybe we should kind of change up the
theme a little bit yeah you know we got
we got a bunch of
miku's probably lying around we probably
resurfaced that every service yeah that
picture of the miku next to the dog i
was like
that is some cursed [ __ ] that looks
photoshopped
i i [ __ ] you know i was i didn't want
to like
swear off this place i thought it was
you know i'm sure i'm sure you know
it's it's very good there has to be a
reason behind it it was it was a nice
place and i just i i really did feel
like they were just like ignorant you
know what i mean
yeah i mean it it like it kind of felt
like they had just like
brought some memorabilia from america
they didn't know what they were buying
well i mean this is what
i really like a lot of the [ __ ] ski
resorts are in the middle of nowhere
yeah it's in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere they
they have no idea about anything like
that what's going on it makes sense but
it's still
it was just super [ __ ] weird because
you walk into this really bizarre
you walk into the last thing you expect
to see in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
in japan yeah cause we had to like
we had to go on a coach that like lasted
about two three hours in the middle of
[ __ ] hokkaido yeah
right so we were going in the middle of
nowhere and we walk in and it's just
like
old american memorabilia everywhere it
was so
[ __ ] bizarre as well the hotel part
was really fancy as well
it's like the entrance this hotel was
like marble like pure marble
with like pillars and it's like what the
[ __ ] is it's so fancy you can get
you can get a helicopter from the
airport to the hotel
[ __ ] hell yeah yeah but then they
just have this whole thing that's like